i've recently
almost done with uh the rise in the fall
of the third reich
it's one of the historical
descriptions of hitler's rise to power
nazis rise to power there's there's a
few philosophical things i'd like
to uh ask you to see if you can help
like one of the things i think about is
uh
how does one be a hero in 1930s nazi
germany what does it mean
to be a hero what do heroic actions
look like i think about that because
i think about how i move about in this
world today
you know that
we live in really chaotic intense
where i don't think you want to draw any
parallels between nazi germany and
modern day
in any of the nations we can think about
but it's not out of the realm of
possibility that
authoritarian governments take hold
authoritarian companies take hold and
i'd like to think that i could be in my
little small way
and inspire others to take the heroic
action
before things get bad and
i kind of try to place myself in what
would 1930s
germany look like is it possible to stop
a hitler
is it even the right way to think about
it
and how does one be a hero in it
i mean you often talk about that living
through a moment in history is very
different than
looking at that history looking you know
when you look back
i also think about it would it be
possible to understand
what's happening that the bells
of war are are ringing
uh it seems that most people didn't seem
to understand
on you know late into the 30s that war
is coming
that's fascinating on the united states
side
inside germany like the opposing figures
the german military didn't seem to
understand this
maybe uh off the other country certainly
france and
uh england didn't seem to understand
this that kind of tried to put myself
into 90s 30s germany as i'm jewish
which is another little twist on the
whole
like what would i do what should one do
do do you have interesting answers
so earlier we had talked about putin and
we had talked about patriotism and love
of country and those sorts of things
in order to be a hero
in nazi germany by our
views here you would have had to have
been
anti-patriotic to the average germans
viewpoint
in the 1930s right you would have to
have opposed your own
government and your own country and
that's a very
it would be a very weird thing to go to
people in germany and say
listen the only way you're going to be
seen as as as a good german
and a hero to the country that will be
your
you know enemies is we think you should
oppose your own government it's
it's a strange position to put the
people
in a government in saying you need to be
against your leader you need to oppose
your government's policies you need to
oppose your government you need to hope
and work for its downfall that doesn't
sound patriotic it wouldn't sound
patriotic
here in this country if you if you made
a similar argument
um i will go away from the 1930s and go
to the 1940s to answer your questions so
there is movements like
the white rose movement in germany which
involved
young people really and and from various
backgrounds
religious backgrounds often who
worked openly against the nazi
government at a time when power was
already consolidated the gestapo was in
full force and they execute people
who are against the government and these
young people would go out and
distribute pamphlets and many of them
got their heads cut off with guillotines
for their trouble
and they knew that that was going to be
the penalty
that is a remarkable amount of bravery
and sacrifice and willingness to die
and almost not even willingness because
they were so open about it it's almost a
certainty
right um that's incredibly moving to me
so when we talk and we talked earlier
about sort of the
human spirit and all that kind of thing
there are people in the german military
who opposed and worked against hitler
for example
but to me that's almost cowardly
compared to what these young people did
in the white rose movement because
those people in the in the vermont for
example who were secretly trying to
undermine hitler
they're they're not really putting their
lives on the line to the same degree
um and so i i think when i look at
heroes
and listen i remember once saying there
were no conscientious
objectors in in germany as a way to
point out
to people that you didn't have a choice
you know you were going to serve in
there and i got letters from jehovah's
witnesses who said
yes there were and we got sent to the
concentration camps
those are remarkably brave things it's
one thing to have
your own um set of of standards and
values
it's another thing to say oh no i'm
going to display them
in a way that with this regime that's a
death sentence and not just for me
for my family right in these regimes
there was not a lot of distinction made
between father and son and wives
that's a remarkable sacrifice to make
and far
beyond what i think i would even be
capable of and so the admiration
comes from seeing people who appear to
be more
morally profound than you are yourself
so when i look at this i look at that
that kind of thing and i just say
wow and the funny thing is if you'd gone
to most
average germans on the street in 1942
and said what do you think of these
people they're going to think of them as
traitors who probably got what they
deserved
so that's the eye of the beholder thing
it's the power of the state
to um to sow propagandize values and
morality
in a way that favors the state uh that
you can turn
people who today we look at as
unbelievably brave and moral
and crusading for righteousness and turn
them into enemies of the people
um so i mean in my mind it would be
people like that
see i i think so
hero is a funny word and we romanticize
the notion
but if i could drag you back to 1930s
germany from 1940s sure
i feel like the heroic actions that
doesn't accomplish
much is not what i'm referring to
so there's many heroes i look up to
that uh like david goggins for example
the guy who runs crazy distances
he runs for no purpose except for the
suffering in itself
and i think his willingness to challenge
the limits of his mind
is uh is heroic i guess i'm looking for
a different term
which is how could hitler have been
stopped
my sense is that he could have been
stopped in the battle of
ideas where or people
millions of people were suffering
economically
or suffering because of the betrayal of
world war one
in terms of the love of country and how
they felt they were being treated
and a charismatic leader that inspired
love
and unity that's not destructive could
have emerged and that's where the battle
should have been fought
i would suggest that we need to take
into account the context
of the times that led to hitler's rise
of power and
and and created the conditions where his
message
resonated that is not a message that
resonates at all times
right um it is impossible to understand
the the rise of hitler without dealing
with the first world war and the
aftermath of the first world
war and the inflationary terrible
depression in germany and all these
things and
the um dissatisfaction with the weimar
republic's government which was often
seen as uh
as uh something put into which was put
into place by the
the victorious powers uh hitler referred
to the people that signed those
agreements uh that
signed the armistice as the november
criminals and
he used that as a phrase which resonated
with the population this was a
population that was embittered and even
if they weren't embittered the times
were so terrible
and the options for operating within the
system in a non-radical way
seemed totally discredited right you
could work through the weimar republic
but they tried and it wasn't working
anyway
and then the alternative to the nazis
who were bully boys in the street
were communist agitators that to the
average conservative germans seem no
better
so you have three options if you're an
average german person
you can go with the discredited
government put in power by
your enemies that wasn't working anyway
you could go with the nazis who seemed
like a bunch of super patriots calling
for
uh the restoration of german authority
or you could go with the communists and
the entire thing
seemed like a litany of poor options
right and
in this realm hitler was able to
triangulate if you will
um he came off
as a person who was going to restore
german greatness at a time when this was
a powerful message but if you don't need
german greatness restored it doesn't
resonate right
um so the reason that your love idea and
all this stuff
i don't think would have worked in the
time period is because that was not a
commodity that the
average german was in search of then
well
it's interesting to think about whether
greatness can be restored
through uh mechanisms through ideas that
are not so
from our perspective today so
evil i don't know what the right term is
but the war
continued in a way so remember that that
when germany when hitler
is rising to power the french are in
control
of parts of germany right the ruler uh
one of the main industrial heartlands of
germany was occupied by the french so
there's never this point where you're
allowed to let the hate
dissipate right every time maybe things
were calming down
something else would happen to stick the
knife in and twist it a little bit more
from the average germans perspective
right
um the reparations right so if you say
okay we're going to get back on our feet
the reparations were crushing
these things prevented the idea of love
or brotherhood and all these things from
taking hold
and even if there were germans who felt
that way and there most certainly were
it is hard to overcome the power of
everyone else you know what i always say
when people talk to me about humanity
is i believe on individual levels we're
capable of
everything and anything good bad or
indifferent but collectively
it's different right and in the time
period
that that we're talking about here
messages of peace on earth and love your
enemies and
and and and all these sorts of things
were absolutely
deluged and overwhelmed and drowned out
by the bitterness the hatred and let's
be honest the sense that you were
continually being abused by your former
enemies
there were a lot of people in the allied
side that realized this and said we're
setting up the next war
this is i mean they understood that you
can only do certain things to collective
human populations
for a certain period of time before it
is natural for them to want to
and there are you can see german posters
from the region nazi propaganda posters
that show them breaking off the chains
of their enemies and i mean germany
awake right that was the
the great um slogan so i think
love is always a difficult option and in
the context of those times
it it was even more disempowered than
normal
well this goes to the just to linger in
it for a little longer
the question of the innova inevitability
of history
do you think hitler could have been
stopped do you think
this kind of force that you're saying
that there was a pain
and was building there's a hatred that
was building
do you think there was a way to avert
i mean there's two questions could have
been a lot worse
and could have been better in in the
trajectory of history in the 30s and 40s
the most logical see we had started this
conversation it brings a wonderful bow
tie into the discussion and
and and buttons it up nicely we had
talked about force and counter force
earlier
uh the most uh obvious and much
discussed way that hitler could have
been stopped has nothing to do with
germans
um when he uh re-militarized the
rhineland
everyone talks about what a couple of
french
divisions would have done had they
simply gone in
and contested and this was something
hitler was extremely i mean it might
have been the most nervous time in his
entire career
because he was afraid that they would
have responded with force
and he was in no position to do anything
about it if they did
so this is where you get the people who
say um
you know i mean and churchill's one of
these people too where they talk about
uh that you know he should have been
stopped militarily right at the very
beginning when he was weak
i don't think
listen there were candidates in the in
the in the catholic center party and
others in in the weimar republic
that maybe could have done things and
it's beyond my understanding of specific
german history to talk about it
intelligently
but i do think that had the french
responded militarily to hitler's initial
moves into that area
that he would have been thwarted and i
think he himself believed if i'm
remembering my reading
um that this would have led to his
downfall so the potential
see i what i don't like about this is
that it almost legitimizes military
intervention
at a very early stage to prevent worse
things from happening
but it might be a pretty clear-cut case
but but it should also be pointed out
that there was a lot of sympathy
on the part of the allies for the fact
that you know the germans
probably should have germany back and
this is traditional german land
i mean they were trying in a funny way
it's almost like
the love and the sense of justice on the
allies part may have actually stayed
their hand
in a way that would have prevented much
much much worse things later but
if the times were such that the message
of a hitler resonated then simply
removing hitler from the equation would
not have removed the context of the
times
and that means one of two things either
you could have had another one
or you could have ended up in a
situation
equally bad in a different direction i
don't know what that means because it's
hard to imagine
anything could be worse than what
actually occurred
but history's funny that way and that's
that hitler is always
everyone's favorite example of the
difference between the great man theory
of history and the trends and forces
theories of history right
the times made a hitler possible and
maybe even desirable to some
if you took him out of the equation
those
trends and forces are still in place
right so what does that mean
if you take him out and the door is
still open does somebody else walk
through it
yeah it's mathematically speaking
the uh the probability of charismatic
leaders emerge
i i'm so torn on that i i'm uh
uh at this point here's another way to
look at it
the institutional um stability
of germany in that time period was not
enough
to push back and there are other periods
in german history i mean that hitler
arose in arizona in 1913
he doesn't get anywhere because
germany's institutional uh
power is enough to simply quash that
it's the fact that germany was unstable
anyway
that prevented a united front that would
have kept radicalism from getting out of
hand does that make sense yes absolutely
you